all right we've decided that we are not
going to interrupt hatred mail during
the virus crisis and everything else
that's going on we need a little levity
in our lives quick reminder about what
hatred mail is
teachers can buy their own school
supplies but we'll throw in the Glock
for free Patriot man written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom all right and it is
time for yet another hatred mail that
needs no introduction take a listen
why not run with the hashtag hashtag bad
Jew this is your calling card Pakman
David Pakman viewer finds out David gay
cancels membership low it's obvious
Pakman isn't gay he has a weird
attraction to Tulsi which he reflected
you as saying her policies are bad
don't call Pakman gay he's not gay
don't say that he's gay cuz he's not
seriously for real not to mention most
left-wingers are gay you can look at
Pakman and notice it yeah hashtag bad
Jew I actually can't tell is this person
more obsessed with me with gay people or
with Tulsi I I don't it seems like a
very strange amalgam of those three
topics as the ones that this hatred is
focused on and I'll remind you you can
fight hate reott ism at this crucial
time by using the coupon code hate reott
40 when you sign up at join pakman.com
that's h80 r io t 4 0 you save 40% off
of your membership and hatreds cry
because their hatred mail is impotent to
hurt the david pakman show yes very good